here to discuss the dramatic Cavanaugh
confirmation and other issues is
Alexander Bolton senior reporter
covering Senate Affairs for the hill
Alex good morning morning you were
actually in the hearing room over the
last few days how exactly did these this
stunning turn of events unfold on Friday
well it seemed like there's gonna be a
pretty routine vote actually Nina
Totenberg who broke the Anita Hill story
way back in 1991 I mean she was talking
to telling us over old war stories some
of the press people some of the
reporters in the room and she said yeah
I think he has the votes and we all
thought the same thing because you know
lakid and moments later flake had issued
his statement he was gonna guess vote
for this nominee because he felt that he
deserved due process and there wasn't
corroborating evidence and so it kind of
seemed like looks like a done deal it
looked like a done deal and so it kind
of played out as you expected
Republicans praising the nominee and
then Democrats just so angry of
bristling in their anger and protesting
walking out
mazie Hirono of Hawaii calling it a
railroad job Kamala Harris of California
refusing even to speak even want to
dignify the proceedings by saying
anything and so they were it was so
tense but yet we thought okay we knew
where this was going we thought we was
gonna wrap up by 1:30 but then we
noticed that flake was kind of staring
down at the dais in front of him this a
flushed look concerned look and he
wasn't speaking they skipped him when it
came to his time to speak yeah and then
he popped out of the room and we were
kind of wondering where's flake but you
know it didn't dawn on us in the room
until what what was going on until right
before he made his big announcement
yeah these proceedings no one would
argue that they are not historic and
they clearly are everyone agrees on that
you've been covering the hill for 20
years
five Supreme Court nominations what's
your take I mean you know I've been
covering Supreme Court nominations since
Chief Justice John Roberts and they've
been pretty boring Affairs quite frankly
you know there's been all this hoopla
over them all this anticipation people
think back to the 1991 Anita Hill
Clarence Thomas showdown thinking it's
going to be another big story and
usually it's a very boring dry discourse
on case
slaw on Supreme Court precedent so we
kind of thought it's gonna be the same
thing again this this time I mean
Kavanagh seems like a squeaky-clean guy
and the confirmation hearings didn't get
a whole lot of the first round didn't
get a whole lot of attention and then
this bombshell revelation that senator
Feinstein had this allegation that she
wouldn't say from whom and then it just
exploded and so as we saw this is now I
mean I look to the front page in New
York time today above the fold
everything is Kavanagh this story is
gripping the nation now we go to an FBI
investigation
Errol touched on this but we have any
sense of the scope and certainly the
timeline they've said less than a week
well they have a week it's not a long
time Chris Coons and Jeff Flake the two
senators who basically catch the deal
they spoke to rod Rosenstein Deputy
Attorney General yesterday on the phone
Rosen see and said yeah the FBI can wrap
this investigation up in a week but
their product I find anything given that
this happened so long ago also the key
witnesses the people that Ford so say
we're at the house
they're already on the record although
not in sworn statements not speaking to
investigators but they're out with
statements through their lawyers saying
that they have no recollection of events
so unless they change their stories it's
hard to see how the FBI is going to
corroborate anything for it says it's
week is an eternity right now in the way
things are moving here and how much is
happening every day this this sort of
open things up again in some way though
well I think the I think the week is
important not so much what the FBI finds
but it gives the it gives the testimony
Cavanaugh's testimony for testimony a
chance to to jail and for the country to
think about it for for people to react
to it for the story to gain momentum and
so that's why the Republican leadership
want a very quick vote they didn't want
that political story to develop any new
if you will that's exactly great that's
why they push for a quick vote and
that's why they were very upset with
flake for asking for that delay right
Alex Bolton thank you we appreciate the
insight thanks for having me